[Musica]
[Applauso]
avete mai fatto pipì nella natura
iniziare così il mio speech da una donna
che vedete è elegante e composta per
alcuni potrebbe sembrare un po' non
stimolo effettivamente ma dovete sapere
che questa è la domanda che mi viene
fatta di più in assoluto sui miei canali
Social da quando ho iniziato a parlare
di cammini zaino e spalla oltre che di
viaggi tradizionali tra virgolette e di
moda Ma Irene ma dove fai la pipì quando
sei nella natura ma ci sono dei bagni
nei boschi Ecco voglio raccontarvi tutto
dall'inizio
Chi di voi durante la pandemia ha dovuto
prendere delle decisioni magari anche
drastiche per la propria vita a me è
successo così è stato un momento un po'
di sconvolgimenti Per esempio io in quel
periodo ho cominciato a riflettere sulle
implicazioni della produzione massiccia
della moda e voi vedrete che c'entra io
vengo da lì perché sono una delle
primissime fashion blogger Con l'avvento
di Instagram poi sono diventata una
fashion influencer ho scritto un libro
di moda sono andata in televisione a
parlare di moda in quel periodo poi
oltretutto ho smesso di mangiare carne
ma anche loro derivati per le loro
implicazioni etiche e sostenibili quindi
in mezzo un po' tutti questi
sconvolgimenti per la mia vita privata
ma anche professionale come potete
immaginare
due desideri si sono fatti strada in me
più forti il desiderio di libertà anni
fa o come tutti non nel periodo della
pandemia e di ritrovare il contatto con
la natura Quindi con il mio fidanzato
che è il compagno un po' di tutte le mie
avventure Abbiamo cominciato un po' a
pensare Ok quando potremo ci
riconquisteremo Nature e libertà natura
Libertà spazi aperti montagna Da lì un
po' per caso è nata l'idea del nostro
primo cammino Zano e spalla abbiamo
fatto 10 giorni in agosto 2020
camminando tra le montagne di rifugio e
il rifugio quella che si chiama Long
iking con uno zaino appunto in spalla
bello impegnativo arrivate alla fine dei
dieci giorni ci siamo guardati negli
occhi e a quel punto eravamo talmente
felici e credoli tra le altre cose che
ci siamo detti Ok adesso non ci fermiamo
più è effettivamente così è stato almeno
fino a questo momento perché da allora
il mio passi conta più di 10 milioni di
passi fatti e 8.000 km camminati perché
da allora abbiamo fatto ben 12 cammini
Zaino in spalla in tre anni e in Italia
e all'estero e la cosa bella è che
insieme a noi dal post pandemia un sacco
di persone hanno iniziato a fare i
cammini a riscoprire i cammini non solo
in Italia Ma anche all'estero in tutto
il mondo
basti pensare che il cammino di Santiago
che forse un po' tutti voi conoscerete
perché è un Praticamente il cammino più
famoso al mondo che attenzione non si fa
soltanto per motivi religiosi ma anche
per tutta un'altra serie di motivazioni
ha avuto un grosso incremento di
camminatori e di Pellegrini
l'Italia che era già un paese di
camminatori di cammini ha avuto un
incremento del numero di camminatori
incremento del numero di camini tant'è
che ogni anno nasce un nuovo cammino
Questa è una cosa meravigliosa Però una
cosa voglio dirvela subito
fare i cammini già in spalla è una
fatica fatica eccolacca fatica è una
fatica perché soprattutto se si decide
di fare un cammino zaino e spalla a
piedi perché Attenzione In alcuni casi
c'è anche modo di farlo non soltanto
camminando ma con modi e mezzi diversi
Se possibile all'inizio Magari ci si
riempie di vesciche come è successo a
noi su un nostro mese del cammino di
Santiago ci possono essere degli
Infortuni delle tendinite così staccate
il collo si cammina sotto il sole si
cammina sotto la pioggia sotto la
grandene capita anche di camminare sotto
la neve in primavera così a caso e
capita anche questo sul terreno e quindi
a questo punto voi vi chiederete Ma
perché
sprecare le proprie vacanze il proprio
tempo libero per fare un cammino sano e
spalla che effettivamente è una cosa
faticosa no come abbiamo visto ci sono
diverse difficoltà Ecco ve lo voglio
raccontare così perché me lo sono
chiesta l'ho chiesto anche alle persone
che mi seguono sui miei canali Social
che come me sono appassionati di cammin
di spalla in primis si fa un cammino per
ritrovare dei ritmi lenti dei ritmi
umani che sono ben diversi dai ritmi
disumani alla quale la nostra società Ci
ha abituati camminando rallentiamo si fa
un cammino già una spalla perché ci si
libera dalle preoccupazioni questo l'ho
vissuto sulla mia pelle perché le uniche
preoccupazioni che si hanno quando si fa
un cammino sono quelle di mangiare bere
riposarsi alla sera Basta cioè proprio i
bisogni primari essenziali ed una cosa
bellissima dei ruota in spalla e che ci
si ferma per pensare ed è un contrasto
forte perché si cammina ma ci si ferma
per pensare perché la mente si libera
totalmente E tu hai quel tempo che non
trovi mai per pensare e cercare delle
soluzioni a dei problemi per stimolare
la creatività perché camminando si
stimola la creatività si dice che sia
anche una forma di meditazione
molte persone poi fanno un cammino Zaino
in spalla per un obiettivo personale
perché ovviamente il cammino presuppone
raggiungere un obiettivo una meta e ci
si accorge lungo questo cammino che
possiamo avere dei limiti che magari non
sapevamo neanche di avere a quel punto
possiamo decidere se superarli oppure
farli propri e una cosa meravigliosa dei
cammini è che è facilissimo fare
amicizia si incontrano un sacco di
persone ed è per questo che tante
persone che fanno cammini partono da
soli e il gancio per incontrare le
persone che hai un obiettivo comune
quello di raggiungere la meta poi
camminare quelle sei sette ore insieme
tutto il giorno ecco ci si conosce
approfonditamente e una cosa che rimane
per sempre nel cuore è la solidarietà
che si vive tra le persone lungo il
cammino ci aiuta tra Pellegrini tra
camminatori ma anche con le persone del
luogo il luogo in cui cammino passa
attraverso ovviamente Il cammino è una
forma di turismo quando si fa un cammino
per vedere cose nuove per visitare il
cammino può passare da Zone già molto
conosciute basti pensare insomma le
nostre zone Però è un turismo diverso
del camminatore vive il luogo dal punto
di vista del sentiero e invece è un
porta un turismo più sostenibile e
responsabile Il cammino può passare
anche delle zone poco conosciute molto
poco conosciute tu camminatori impari
qualcosa di nuovo e allo stesso tempo Il
cammino riesce e l'ho visto con i miei
occhi ad utilizzare lo spopolamento di
piccoli Borghi o delle zone altrimenti
dimenticate E se mi chiedete qual è la
cosa che mi piace di più dei cammini
cosa molto difficile perché tutto ciò
che vi ho detto sono cose meravigliose
per me forse è che ho imparato a
rimettere un po' in discussione le cose
importanti della mia vita per esempio ho
imparato che 8 kg di zaino sulle spalle
per un mese quindi di cose personali
sulle spalle 8 kg sono sufficienti non
servirebbe tanto altro in realtà e
questo mi ha ridimensionata molto poi ho
superato un mio limite grosso che era
quello di dormire contatti sconosciuti
Uomini e donne insieme in una stessa
stanza e poi quanto è bello mangiare una
pasta al pomodoro semplicissima oppure
una minestra la sera dopo che però hai
camminato per le 6 7 ore sotto la
pioggia e poi quando cammini in salita
arrivi in cima al Monte e sa che dopo
c'è soltanto la discesa sei super
soddisfatto prendi il tuo panino lo
mangi con una vista incredibile ed è
quello che io chiamo il ristorante a 5
stelle perché non c'è veramente di
meglio così quando le persone vi dicono
hanno fatto un cammino zaino e spalla e
il cammino gli ha cambiato la vita io
posso dirvi che è così perché il cammino
la vita da certe persone la mette
completamente in discussione sicuramente
imparare anche a fare la pipì nella
natura ed il bello è che chiunque può
partire per questa avventura basta
prendere uno zaino e andare
[Applauso]